let's think about the situation where we
have a completely fair coin here so let
me draw it i'll assume it's a quarter or
something let's see so this is a quarter
let me draw my best attempt at a profile
of george washington well that'll do so
it's a fair coin and we're going to flip
it a bunch of times and figure out the
different probabilities so let's start
with a straightforward one let's just
flip it once so with one flip of the
coin what's the probability of getting
heads well there's two equally likely
possibilities and the one with heads is
one of those two equally likely
possibilities so there's a one-half
chance same thing if we were to ask what
is the probability of getting tails
there are two equally likely
possibilities and one of those gives us
tails so one half and so and this isn't
one thing to realize if you take the
probabilities of heads plus the
probabilities of tails you get one half
plus one half which is one and this is
generally two the probability the sum of
the probabilities of all of the possible
events should be equal to one and that
makes sense because you're taking you're
adding up all of these fractions and the
numerator will then add up to all of the
possible events the denominator is
always all of the possible events so you
have all the possible events over all
the possible events when you add all of
these things up now let's take it up a
notch
let's figure out the probability of i'm
going to take this coin and i'm going to
flip it twice the probability of getting
heads and then getting another heads
the probability of getting a head and
then another head so there's two there's
two ways to think about it
one way is to just think about all the
different possibilities i could get a
head on the first flip and a head on the
second flip head on the first flip tail
on the second flip i could get
tails on the first flip heads on the
second flip or i could get tails on both
flips so there's four
distinct equally likely possibilities
four distinct equally likely outcomes
here and one way to think about it is on
the first flip i have two possibilities
on the second flip i have another two
possibilities i could have heads or
tails heads or tails and so i have four
possibilities for each of these
possibilities for each of these two i
have two possibilities here so either
way i have four equally likely
possibilities and how many of those meet
our constraints
well we have it right over here this one
right over here having two heads meets
our constraints
so this is and there's only one of those
possibilities i've only circled one of
the four scenarios so there's a
one-fourth chance of that happening
another way you could think about this
and this is because these are
independent events and this is a very
important idea to understand in
probability and we'll also study
scenarios that are not independent but
these are independent events the the
what what happens in the first flip in
no way affects what happens in the
second flip and this is actually one
thing that many people don't realize
there's something called the gambler's
fallacy where someone thinks if i got a
bunch of heads in a row then all of a
sudden it becomes more likely on the
next flip to get a tails that is not the
case every flip is an independent event
what happened in the past in these flips
does not affect the probabilities going
forward so the probability of getting
your heads on the first flip in no way
or the fact that you got a heads on the
first flip in no way affects that you
got a heads on the second flip so if you
can make that assumption you could say
that the probability of getting heads
and heads or heads and then heads is
going to be the same thing as getting
probability
as the probability of getting heads on
the first flip
times the probability of getting heads
on the second flip and we know the
probability of getting heads on the
first flip is one half and the
second flip is one half and so we have
one half times one half which is equal
to one fourth which is exactly we got
what we got when we tried out all of the
different scenarios all of the equally
likely possibilities
let's take it up another notch
let's figure out the probability
and we've kind of been ignoring tails so
let's pay some attention to tails the
probability of getting tails
and then heads and then tails so this
exact series of events so i'm not saying
two you know in any in any order two
tails and a head i'm saying this exact
order the first flip is the tails second
flip is a heads and then third flip is a
tail so once again these are all
independent events what the fact that i
get tails on the first flip in no way
affects the probability of getting heads
on the second flip and that in no way
affects the probability of tails on the
third flip so because these are
independent events we can say this is
the same thing as the probability of
getting tails on the first flip
times the probability of getting heads
on the second flip times the probability
of getting tails on the third flip and
we know these are all independent events
so this right over here is one-half
times
one-half
one-half times one-half is one-fourth
one-fourth times one-half is equal to
one-eighth so this is equal to
one-eighth and we can verify it let's
try out all of the different scenarios
again so you could get heads
heads heads you could get heads heads
tails you could get heads tails heads
you could get heads
tails tails
you can get you can get tails
heads heads
this is a little tricky sometimes you
want to make sure you're being exhausted
in all of the different possibilities
here you could get you could get tails
tails
heads
tails you could get tails
tails
heads or you could get tails tails tails
and what we see here is that we got
exactly eight equally likely
possibilities
we have eight equally likely
possibilities and the tail heads tails
is exactly one of them it is this
possibility right over here so it is one
of eight equally likely possibilities